Um, and I got to Tik TOK, dude. How about that?
Have you guys been on tick tock, tick docks, the worst app.
Do you guys know that?
How come they always have to spell it differently to tick? Like what, what,
what, what spells more wrong? Uh, apps or rappers?
You know what I mean? Like all eyes on me with a Z or tick tock,
T I K T O K
Tik TOK is the worst app of all time. And it's all good,
but it's sorta worst of all time. And I did one,
I did a bunch last night and I was howling dude, how bad they are.
They're so bad even doing them makes me cringe.
Even though I'm making fun of it. I put on my Instagram, I said,
this is my impression of a 12 year old. And it was like, and they're all like,
how come everybody on tic-tac when they're doing tech jobs,
they have to look up to the left like this
and what do they got to do that? They're just like, w w w w eight.
I saw a guy do a Tik TOK. Can we go on,
is there like a tick tock.com or do I have to see it on my only on the phone?
Yeah, but there's, there's YouTubes. They upload them to YouTube babies.
That's why you're on fire. He doesn't think of the things that I think of
a tick tock. Here we go. Look at these tick talks, bro. Some of the,
I saw tick-tock the other day. You know how that guy, Cameron,
something that Disney kid died do,
there was like a 11 year old that was like playing the beginning of a song.
And it said like, Carmen, yada, yada was pronounced dead.
And the kid was just like this, like feeling it like pretending to cry.
And then he just like, went like this and that was the tick-tock Hey guy,
Hey dude. If you're my kid, I'll have words with you
have words with your kids. If they're pretending to be email on Tik TOK.
Seriously, dude. That's how I know I'm an old guy finally, besides my back pain.
That's how I know I'm an old guy is that there's a really popular app finally.
And I don't, I just can't tick tock, tick tock,
dude, go yourself. You know, let's look at some of these though.
Top 10, best tick tock challenges. Why is everything a challenge to you?
Just hit record tick.
Tocks that keep me happy in summer. Oh, this'll be a good one.
I'll walk around. Like,
I mean just so bad audio, such bad audio. Me.
What is this? How to get taller?
I mean, Jesus, mother. You know,
girls in her pajamas, just jumping around.
All right. I can't even, I mean, it's not even worth it, you know? That's how,
but they always go like,
Oh, what's that song that they,
the distance is that Justin Bieber one. Oh, it is baby.
That's like his first song right? Ever Tik TOK is like that.
Like,
dude, it's a weird dude. Everything's so weird.
Tic TOK c'mon. Oh, they're killing it though, man. How do you make,
I don't think money sponsors, I guess.
Anyway, get it. Don't get a tick-tock somebody just comments on my app.
Eat your cat challenge. Kay.
I still haven't gotten Neo's Cammy. I got to get in.